we begin today with new developments in  that deadly jet crash near nellis air  force base happened yesterday afternoon  in a neighborhood off christie lane  that's near kerry and nellis  a short time ago the coroner's office  released the identity of the pilot who  was killed in that crash  he is 43 year old nicholas hunter of las  vegas this is the aftermath yesterday  hunter worked for draken u.s that's a  company that provides adversary air  support to the base  no one on the ground was hurt yesterday  but we did speak with neighbors nearby  about  what they saw a lot of things i've seen  in my life that's probably  the number one thing that  scared me i'm 86 years old and  i never seen anything like that in my  life only on tv  the national transportation safety board  has now taken over the investigation  and it could be a while before the cause  of the crash is released but we'll bring  it to you just as soon as we can